[Musique]
jack kerouac est une des gens de la beat
generation est un des plus grands
écrivains américains du 20e siècle jack
kerouac les intemporels peut-être même
immortel d'un point de vue littéraire
il devrait inspirer plein de monde si je
pense je pense bien sûr à des bobs des
loges face à jim morrison
je tape à l'oeil comme rester au canada
ou malades et des cortons découle qu'est
né à lowell au massachusetts en 1922
jean-louis kerouac avaient des parents
québécois originaire du bas saint
laurent celui qui se faisait appeler
tiges en a parlé seulement français
jusqu'à l'âge de 6 ans longtemps resté
inédit des écrits en français ont vu le
jour dans le recueil intitulé la vie est
dommage il y eu ce passage extradant la
bouleverser wenzi 1 à caen quand je me
fâche chaque souvent un frein c'est
quand je rangerai souvent français et
quand je braille jeu brand est toujours
en français et qui j'ai mal il se
pouvait tourner mais de son vivant c'est
en anglais que jack kerouac à publier
ses écrits il ya eu ce premier roman en
1950 puis la consécration en 1957 grâce
à son deuxième livre intitulé sur la
route une phrase que littéraire qui
allait pousser ses admirateurs à partir
à l'aventuré
je suis pas là à la poursuite de kerouac
mais je pense que kerouac nous poursuit
toujours quand votre seul dans le désert
à rouler en moto le bairro kerouac à 6
sièges à chalabre 6 ou 5 b you mais si
je clique
l'histoire exposé sur la route est le
fruit de plusieurs années de voyages et
d'écriture acharné il ya du sexe de la
drogue et du jazz sur une route faite de
rencontres jack kerouac est devenu avec
ses amis mirou cassady wannian blu ray
allen ginsberg un des piliers de la vie
de générations des années 1950 savigny
la beat generation la beat generation
c'est oui et le rythme mais c'est
d'abord militant d'abord battu lui même
le dit jeta les loups et même encore
aujourd'hui le fantôme de jack kerouac à
bec cloué sainte marie qui chantera
doute ses textes sur son prochain album
et à
conduire
dans tout le site tiens
n'habite mois comme comme canadienne
french cancan mais oui parce que ils
possèdent la langue il est besoin par
lui j'apprends qui suit j'apprends mon
histoire j'apprends ce que j'ai retenu
j'apprends c'est alors ça j'ai eu envie
de chanter le chiffre bons légumes et
gratuit j'ai prêché points comme le
courage
jack kerouac a publié dix sept livres et
plusieurs inédits ont vu le jour après
son décès son histoire demeure un des
grands mythes de l'amérique moderne sont
fiers de kerouac les américains dont
québec on devrait être fiers aussi
d'ailleurs provoquer maux de tête une
bonne soufflante
lot de la robe j'en appelle à la poésie
et à la sculpture de québec jack kerouac
est décédé en 1969 en floride il avait
47 ans ici à nouveau le massachusetts on
célébrera son 100e anniversaire de
naissance ce samedi avec tous ces
hommages des résidents de l'osce sont
déterminés à garder bien vivante la
mémoire de jack kerouac ici douicher
depuis mai radio-canada
massachusetts